so all of the lies from the
administration about the Russian
Bounty's story have completely imploded
and fallen apart and the reason that
they fallen apart is that even if the
lies were true they would only expose
new problems so let me give you an
example if Trump really hadn't been
briefed about the Russian Bounty's
situation that's the problem why wasn't
he briefed that would be an absolute and
total disaster given that we know the
topic got to the National Security
Council if the Russian Bounty's
situation was in his presidential daily
briefing months ago why doesn't he
remember is it a memory problem that's
also a huge problem in other words the
explanations we've heard so far if true
would all just be indicative of
additional new and even bigger problems
and to sort of reset the story the news
broke over the weekend that there were
reportedly Russian bounties these are
like cash bonuses offered to Taliban
linked fighters if they were able to
kill us or coalition troops in
Afghanistan they would get a cash bonus
ok that's absolutely and utterly insane
initially the White House was silent for
I believe it was 24 hours Trump was not
briefed about it we were told multiple
reports came out later that Trump had
been briefed as early as 2019 to as
recently as spring and eventually we got
to the specific claim that the bounty
report was in his presidential daily
briefing in February so at a press
briefing yesterday Donald Trump's press
secretary Kaylee McKenna knee was asked
why isn't Trump reading the PDB in other
words if it was in there and Trump
doesn't know about it
is he not reading it does he not
remember and Caylee goes bonkers saying
Trump is the most informed person on the
planet on issues related to threats
against the United States take a listen
ask you maybe to defend why the
president is necessarily reading of PD
when there are these exhibitions it
arrives the president does read and he
also consumes intelligence verbally this
president I'll tell you is the most
informed person on planet earth when it
comes to the threats that we face
you have ambassador O'Brien who sees him
in person twice a day who sometimes
takes the upwards of half a dozen calls
with this president he's constantly
being informed and briefed on
intelligence matters but I'm not going
to allow the New York Times to dictate
when we give top-secret information and
don't give top-secret information the
lie falls apart when you go too far when
Trump once said I'm the least racist
person in the world
it was too hyperbolic right just say
you're not racist it would be not
believable if you're Trump but it would
be more believable than I'm the least
racist person in the world same thing
here
Trump is the most informed person in the
world on threats to America he doesn't
even read his own presidential daily
briefings just say he's informed like
just be less hyperbolic and it would be
less obviously unbelievable and I think
that the the sort of key reminder here
is let's not take our eye off the ball
the the three key points about the
Russian bounty story are number one they
seem to have lied again Trump was
briefed or told about this in some way
shape or form multiple sources and
allegations that he was told either in
2019 or February of this year or the
spring of this year or in all of those
instances that's number one that's
really important they lied again number
two the lies they told if true are only
indicative of other arguably just as big
problems like why wouldn't Trump have
been briefed about it number three
Trump was briefed and he still wanted
Russia back in the g7 to make at the g8
he still withheld arms from Ukraine that
they would have used to defend
themselves against Russian aggression
that's absolutely crazy and I guess
number four I said it was three things
but there's four Trump has certainly
been briefed by now right we know now
he's been briefed so now the question is
what is he going to do about it
now that he's been briefed and
without a doubt knows about it and the
answer is nothing Trump actually tweeted
this morning I don't have to tweet handy
but he essentially tweeted he doesn't
believe the story like he's just
dismissing the story despite the fact
that we have officials of all kinds
saying it's a credible story it's a real
story it's a story we should believe so
that's just as important Trump now has
been briefed doing something no he's not
doing anything
he's just dismissing the story as
completely fake those are the main four
points that we should be thinking about
again when we recognize the importance
of removing this terror as we get closer
and closer to November